I have my answer to this question but is
it healthy to go for sixty days without
washing yeah I was fascinated hearing
this before absolutely our skin is made
to protect itself and you know in Stone
Age we didn't have a shower every day in
the morning you know you use your shower
gel with colorants and perfume and
preservatives and you love this yeah you
will irritate the skin and in the
evening after you did your exercise
again you have the same whole procedure
and it's very aggressive and his skin
looks very healthy to me it survived
this face without having a shower you
know sometimes you you have a lake or a
river and then you decide as a natural
boy and a boy to jump in and wash off
the dirt the you know that the dirt you
see and the lovely bacteria remain there
where they are and protect him the next
60 days but do you so so that what
you're saying is first the the skin
doesn't want us to shower well if you
would ask the skin just when would you
like to shower again it would sit and
think and say well maybe next week or
whenever so you don't shower I shower
but I do a compromise as a dermatologist
and know how aggressive all these
washing substances and disinfection
substances are so what I do is I take a
shower every day indeed I hope you like
my email I would never say anything else
but I use only water and sometimes I use
a very mild washing substance a sin-debt
so called it's not a soap because sin
Nets have an acidic ph value so less is
more regarding to skin care when you
tell me that I should that I should
exercise my what do you call it this
muscle did south boot yeah yeah it's yes
that's a technical sin every day well
this came about because I had chronic
back pain for ten years really bad back
pain had to often I'd have to take time
off work
the one time I was off for six weeks
couldn't work when my kids were born I
couldn't lift up my son I felt just
worthless and I tried everything until I
found a guy who actually really managed
to help me and he said really although
it's in your back I think the problem is
is that your right foot and your right
glutes so my right bum muscles basically
not working and he gave me some very
simple exercise it's like two or three
minutes to do a day and literally within
days my back pain vanishes and has not
come back since when you talk about
these these exercises for the bum
what could could you could you show us
just I mean one of them just so one of
those that there are really simple yeah
okay so sure there's four of them but
let me get one that will work here
without a stat for example it's
something called foot clocks and we have
to stand up okay okay yes I do my life
thought you just following clocks really
from 11 o'clock all the way around to 6
o'clock so you've sort like this 12
o'clock uh-huh one o'clock see the clock
right and this is activating your left
gluts as you do that but in every sort
of range of motion so 11 12 could you do
this to music yeah it's like you could
play maybe while I do this staying alive
by the Bee Gees yeah I'm just you have
this very appealing theory about
exercise yes it is similar in a way
because the interesting thing about
fasting one of the ways it seems to work
is it stresses your body and there are
some forms of stress which are good when
you exercise you do weights and things
like that what you actually do is you
tear muscle and then the body repairs
the muscle and it makes it stronger and
so what they say about fasting is it
stresses the body and it is the repair
that takes place that actually does the
good now I have been investigating
something called hit high-intensity
training which all athletes do short
periods of really pushing yourself now
this has been done in athletics for 6070
years what is new is it's being
introduced for people who are not fit
and what is really astonishing about it
is that you can get many of the benefits
of exercise from
one minute done three times a week and
this is the part I like yeah three
minutes a week three minutes we yeah
that's all yeah but it has to be intense
its intense oh I do it on an exercise
bike and you basically go flat out for
20 seconds if I had an exercise bike
here I would demonstrate but you can do
it swimming you can do it running you
just have to go intense is it is it a
big difference between the quality or
what is more most important the quality
or the the quantity of sleep we used to
think it was quantity and the advice
we've give is you know somewhere around
eight hours of sleep and and you asked
me the question you know I certainly
give myself a non-negotiable 8 hour
sleep opportunity not because I want to
be a poster child or sort of you know
practice what I preach if you understood
the importance of sleep as I do you it's
selfish you would choose to do nothing
other than give yourself that's the you
know I don't want disease or sickness I
don't want a shorter life I want a
longer life and a longer healthier life
and it's the best insurance policy that
I know of in terms of health care
so certainly quantity is important but
probably in the last five or six years
quality is also critical - it's a
combination of the two so just because
you may be in bed for eight hours if
you're not getting that continuous sleep
and the deep quality sleep first and
then the sort of the dream sleep later
in the night you need all of these
things to get those benefits I have in
trouble
talking about cancer it's very much
about the genes I understand but it's
also about lifestyle it's also about
whether you smoke or not absolutely how
important is stress so the word stress
is a colloquial word you see the word
stress means different things to
different people and if you take the
most colloquial definition of stress
which is the kind of thing that we you
know though the feeling that you have
before you have a major examination or a
television interview that as far as we
know
that doesn't cause cancer I hope not
there are other forms of stress which
are biological forms of stress such as a
kind of chronic inflammation that is
also a stress it is a it's a biological
stress it is a stress that's mediated by
particular hormones by particular invite
inflammatory environments and that does
cause cancer so the word stress is a if
from the standpoint of biology has many
meanings so many meanings that it
actually becomes meaningless does it
help to think positive yeah I mean in
the sense that it depends again what
you're asking does it is just positive
there's a positive attitude allow you to
face the day bring you to the clinic
allow you to face the chemotherapy yes
it does does it cause cancer no there's
a negative attitude cause cancer no if
this idea that negative attitudes cause
cancer is a classic example of blaming
the victim don't get me wrong about what
it means to be positive but also don't
don't blame the victim for having cancer
if I had cancer I would have a
profoundly negative attitude as well I
mean I wouldn't be a happy person in the
morning let me tell you that because
this is actually about that we in the
Western world we never we never we're
never really hungry yes we just we just
peckish absolutely I mean because part
of the advice has been for many years
now never get hungry keep on having more
meals the time between meals has dropped
from about when I was a child my mother
said never eat between meals
now people snack they eat at you know
11:00 in the morning they eat lunch they
eat at 4:00 in the afternoon and
actually all the evidence is that a lot
of the repair takes place during the
time when you are not eating so for
typically you go to bed at night maybe
nine o'clock in I'm sorry you stopped
eating at night at about nine o'clock
maybe and then you don't eat again until
8:00 so you have eleven hours of that
food during that period a lot of
cellular repair takes place so if you
keep on eating all the time then your
body never gets
anything less wouldn't solve it no you
basically need longer periods without
food is what research a few hours ago I
had lunch alright where is what is
happening I mean it's how long time does
it take well I hope you liked what you
ate
did you yeah well III think it was Peaks
meet or something okay
um so I think the first thing always is
um I'm a big supporter of the idea and
that the body is smart actually and I
hope you enjoyed and liked what you ate
because I think many of those in
intuitions aren't bad really they are
might might be a bit misled by food
industry but if you eat something and
you think it's it's nice and you like it
then that's fine so if I if I like pork
then it's okay well yeah and you know a
little bit yeah I got then you may be a
little senseless you know more sensible
to using knowledge as well to have a
smarter body feeling they could say like
after two or three hours it's gone down
the esophagus and it has been in the
stomach and now it's being taken up in
my blood slowly
pork may be a little longer but some
litem use two or three hours and then
you can say how do I feel now because
when you eat something like a piece of
cake or maybe a really really huge piece
of pork then you're like ah this is
fantastic it tastes so great and then
two or three hours later you might be
very tired and if you'd just eaten some
vegetables not the big piece of cake you
might be hungry again soon but you don't
feel as tired for example those are
experiments you could do with knowledge
and you can do them yourself and then
you can see how do I like this and you
have a smarter body feeling so anyone
suggesting that they can survive on five
or four hours of sleep is a fallacy and
you know it strikes me as interesting
one of the most significant lifestyle
factors determining whether or not you
will develop Alzheimer's disease is the
amount of sleep that you're getting
because at night there is this
remarkable cleansing system that kicks
into high gear
that washes away the toxic proteins that
are linked to Alzheimer's disease so you
get this power cleanse at night it's
sort of good night's sleep clean you
know technology is a problem the image
sort of issue I think is is problematic
alcohol those two are not the friends of
sleep itself only only caffeine in in
the morning or yes so caffeine in the
morning is okay you know a couple or two
in the morning but one of the problems
with caffeine is that it has a half-life
of about six hours and it has a quarter
life of 12 hours what that means is that
if you have a cup of coffee at noon a
quarter of that caffeine is still
circulating in your brain at midnight so
if you have a cup of coffee you know
around midday it's the equivalent of
getting into bed at night and before you
turn the light out you Swick a quarter
of a cup of coffee and you hope for a
good night of sleep it's just not going
to happen and how cool is that all in
the morning
it's strange but alcohol is again a
group of drugs that we call the sedative
so again you're just knocking yourself
out with the nightcap alcohol also
litters your sleep with many more
awakenings
it's called fragmented sleep so you
don't feel as restored by your sleep the
next morning
and finally alcohol is a very powerful
drug at blocking your dream sleep and so
the advice that you know I would never
give on a television program in front of
a public audience would be yes you
should go to the pub in the morning by
the evening the alcohol is a cue system
and you're just fine but I would never
say that as as a professional you know
can we cut that too no hope you enjoyed
the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe
you